[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Парк «Тузловські лимани»,
Бессарабія]
Тут можна побачити — як на Малому Сасику,
так і на Шаганах,
зграї рожевих пеліканів.
Якщо пощастить, можна побачити кучерявого.
От особисто я зараз бачу
і чапель, і пеліканів,
[Ірина Бурлаченко
Співробітниця парку «Тузловські лимани»]
і куликів, і качок різних.
Близько 20 тисяч гектар —
це водна гладь.
Система озер Шагани-Алібей-Бурнас —
це водно-болотні угіддя
міжнародного значення.
В першу чергу, для водоплавних птахів.
Цією територією проходить
один з найбільших міграційних шляхів.
Саме тут вони відпочивають, харчуються,
набирають жирок, щоб мати енергію
і здійснювати величезні перельоти.
Це птахи в реальному розмірі.
[Іван Русєв
Співробітник парку «Тузловські лимани»]
Найбільших птах у нас — кучерявий пелікан.
Розмах його крил —
три метри десять сантиметрів.
На цій ділянці був шлагбаум,
через який проїжджали
дуже багато браконьєрів.
Тут було багато точок, де полювали мисливці
в різні пори року.
Це була дуже важка і важлива робота,
щоб знайти формулу примирення.
Коли ми почали працювати,
нам говорили, що ці люди не хочуть визнавати
парк як такий і як державну установу.
Вони почали чинити нам спротив.
Тоді ми вимушені були залучити волонтерів,
щоб очистити цю територію
в прямому і переносному сенсі.
Тут було дуже багато сміття,
дуже багато гільз від патронів.
Нам погрожували, а тому
ми повинні були діяти дуже швидко.
Волонтери допомагали
з'ясувати відносини між нами.
Були бійки.
Одного разу навіть браконьєри
намагалися спалити вагончик інспекторів,
коли вони інспектували ділянку.
Волонтери змогли пов'язати цих браконьєрів.
Після цього настав період нашого переважання над браконьєрами.
Ми почали працювати
над спорудженням об'єктів,
які приваблювали би туристів.
Ми зараз знаходимося на території,
яка є прибережною захисною смугою лиману Шагани.
Прибережні захисні смуги встановлюються для того,
щоб вберегти водний об'єкт
від забруднення,
від антропогенного навантаження.
Але що ми маємо по факту?
Вони скрізь знищені.
Це абсолютно деградована ділянка,
тому що тут відбувається прогон скота.
Громадських пасовищ немає.
Прибережні захисні смуги
абсолютно ніде не дотримані.
Фактично всі прибережні землі
там, де можна орати,
все розорано.
Це є самозахоплення земель.
Ніхто не реагує.
Я можу надати масу листів,
ми стукали абсолютно у всі двері.
Ми самотужки будемо шукати кошти для того,
щоб відновлювати ці межові знаки.
Так ми мінімізуємо,
а можливо й повністю ліквідуємо
всі ті земельні конфлікти,
які ми наразі маємо.
З 2016 року ми страшенними зусиллями
повернули державі і природі 130 гектар.
В порівнянні з тим, що ми маємо
більше двох тисяч гектар
вкрадених земель — це мізер.
Люди насправді не розуміють
цінності цих водно-болотних угідь.
Ми намагаємося доносити до людей,
наскільки угіддя важливі і що вони мають
функціонувати в природному стані.
Степ — не менш цінна екосистема
у боротьбі зі змінами клімату.
Степові ділянки поглинають вуглець
набагато більше,
ніж ліси і водні екосистеми.
У степу велика кількість комах,
які запилюють поля.
Збереження природних екосистем —
цих степових ділянок —
важливе в першу чергу для аграріїв.
Чому до землі таке ставлення?
Цьогоріч на ділянці, яку ми відвоювали,
ми вперше спостерігали леженя.
Цей птах занесений до Червоної книги.
Ця ділянка дуже важлива
у міграційний період журавлів.
Тут є багато видів дрібних ссавців,
які теж дуже важливі для степу.
Тут колись мешкав ховрах одеський,
а зараз він зник.
Ми плануємо відновити його популяцію.
Ще ми мріємо відновити популяцію
бабака степового.
Ми зараз маємо ділянку...
Сподіваюся, ми знайдемо кошти для того,
щоб огородити цю ділянку від людей
і дати тваринам змогу
відновити свої поселення.
Якщо цього немає, то види зникають.
Немає збалансованого розвитку цієї біосфери
і людини в тому числі.
Валет, Валетик, Валет.
Привіт, Валетик.
Доброго ранку.
— Ти вже тут?
— Та я вже давно чекаю.
Забирайте.
Вас турбують з національного парку.
Команда зараз буде виходити на Тузловську групу.
Човном, перепрошую.
Зареєстрованим, а яким же?
Від кордону убік, а там далі буде видно.
Наша команда, яка створилася 3,5 роки тому,
свідома того, що це довкілля
важливе не тільки для сьогодення,
а і для майбутнього — для функціонування
біосфери для майбутніх поколінь.
Дані наших моніторингів лягають в звіти,
в оперативну інформацію для міністерств та чиновників іншої ланки.
Є різні напрями: наприклад,
ми плануємо визначити солоність води.
Ми беремо спеціальний пристрій
(солемір) та їдемо в парк.
Ми маємо пляшки, ми беремо пробу,
а потім в лабораторії ми вивчаємо солоність води.
Якщо ми рахуємо птахів...
У нашому відділі є орнітолог,
він має біноклі, квадрокоптер.
Він вивчає ті ділянки, які є у нас в плані.
Такі моніторинги та спостереження
потім лягають в літопис природи.
Це є галагаз — дуже яскравий птах.
Ми тут маємо дитячий садочок для цих пташок.
Ух ти, яка краса!
Дякую.
Земля.
Це унікальний організм,
у ньому є золото.
Тисячна доля золота.
Це дуже цінний корм для камбали, для птахів.
У нас дуже багато їжі для птахів.
Особливо в водах тринадцяти лиманів
ми маємо різні види гідробіотнів:
маленькі черв’ячки, мушлі,
риби різних видів.
Але немає місць для гніздування птахів.
Так формується екосистема,
що є багато піщаних кос,
але вони дуже привабливі
для наземних хижаків.
Коли птахи починають гніздуватися,
хижаки вночі дістають ці гнізда і руйнують їх.
Тому три роки тому ми
почали будувати штучні острови.
Дуже вдало.
Ми зараз маємо сім островів,
на яких вже третій рік поспіль багато птахів.
Я все своє життя мріяв про те,
щоб моя робота була й моїм хобі.
Кожного ранку я прокидаюся з думками
знайти щось яскраве.
Зараз я — начальник наукового відділу.
Мій день починається з того, що
я заздалегідь планую, куди я поїду.
Але кожного ранку я мрію бути всюди,
де є наша екосистема.
Щомиті ти можеш спостерігати явище,
яке більше ніколи не повториться.
Я мрію зафіксувати це
в записах, фотографіях, відео...
Це триває впродовж дня.
Я закінчив університет,
стажувався в біологічному напрямі,
захистив дві дисертації.
Я знаю, якщо ти не будеш
вести моніторинг екосистеми,
ти втрачаєш можливість керувати
екосистемою в майбутньому.
Ще в радянські часи я опинився
біля Аральського моря.
Аральське море — це екосистема,
яка дуже багата на різноманіття.
Вірніше, була такою,
поки радянська влада не почала
знищувати Амудар'ю і Сирдар'ю.
Це дві великі річки,
які живили Аральське море.
Я там працював і на власні очі бачив,
як зникає Аральське море.
Воно відходить від берегу,
кораблі лягають на бік.
Посуха, солоне повітря...
Люди тікали від цього моря.
Коли я це побачив, почав працювати
не заради вивчення природи,
а й її захисту.
Люди поважного віку жили в
радянській системі, де казали,
що ми маємо заповідники,
а вони — для секретарів райкому.
Не було поваги до природоохоронних територій.
Ми працюємо з цим поколінням,
знаходимо співпрацю.
Мине час, і мешканці Татарбунарського
району зрозуміють,
що національний парк — передусім для них.
Збережені ресурси — це надовго,
а не тільки на сьогодні.
Я працюю інспектором з охорони.
Працюю уже три роки.
Потрапив сюди через друга.
Перші півроку було якось
дико працювати в цій сфері,
а потім закохався в свою роботу.
[Руслан Лупашко
Спіробітник «Тузловські лимани»]
Зазвичай ставлять
такі палки, нашивають на ятер
і потім — виловлюють рибу.
Мій звичайний робочий день
буває з четвертої ранку...
З п'ятої.
Десь до восьмої-десятої.
Коли починається сезон полювання та рибальства,
більш напружений графік.
Працюємо, можна сказати, 24/7.
Це починається з серпня
і закінчується в жовтні.
Найбільш гарячий період.
У мене відбулася зустріч з браконьєрами.
Це сталося в лютому,
було холодно.
Вони підпалили камиші,
розташувалися по периметру
і холоднокровно чекали,
поки звірі вийдуть.
Разом з ними був неповнолітній,
який переймав досвід у свого родича.
Це історія...
Вона мені запам'ятається надовго.
Болюча така.
Я — місцевий житель, з села Жовтий Яр.
Я тут народився, тут виріс.
Скоріш за все, я б продовжив тут працювати.
Назвімо це моєю невеличкою місією.
У мене є бажання зберегти такі гарні і
цікаві місця для наступних поколінь.
Робити хоч мінімальний внесок для того,
щоб принаймні залишилося те,
що є зараз.
Відвідування парку є абсолютно безкоштовним.
Ви приїжджаєте сюди.
Навіть якщо немає екскурсовода,
завжди є служба охорони,
яка покаже вам напрямок руху.
Ви підете і не заблукаєте.
Якщо вас цікавить бунгало — будь ласка.
Самостійно йдете, спостерігаєте за птахами
годину, дві, три, п'ять — скільки душа бажає.
Бунгало зробили наші волонтери.
Це були аудитори.
Аудиторська компанія досить серйозна.
Молоді люди приїхали і долучилися
до такої благородної справи.
Попрацювали з нами.
Зараз наші відвідувачі мають можливість
скористатися цим бунгало.
Є такі люди, а це передусім бьордвотчери,
які ночували в цьому бунгало.
Вони йдуть туди звечора.
Ти прокидаєшся,
птахи не знають
про твою присутність поруч
і спокійно ходять
перед тобою туди-сюди.
Можна насолодитися
і класні знімки зробити.
Бьордвотчери — це для мене такі люди...
Я не знала про них до роботи в парку,
а зараз дивлюся на них:
це в хорошому сенсі такі диваки класні.
Вони ладні їхати за тисячі кілометрів,
ходити в погоду, в непогоду,
годинами сидіти, спостерігати й дивитися.
Просто круто.
Я так бачу, це доволі
популярний напрям в нашій країні.
Це лікарі, фізики, хто завгодно за професією.
У нас був такий випадок, коли зі Швейцарії сім'я,
вже поважного віку люди,
спеціально літаком прилетіли до Одеси,
винайняли авто, приїхали в наш парк для того,
щоб побачити один вид конкретної пташки.
Я — журналіст із Financial Day, Нідерланди.
Моє хобі — бьордвотчінг.
Тут за кілька годин я побачив один вид птахів, який я ніде до того не бачив на власні очі.
[Васко ван дер Бун
Бьордвотчер]
Це місце унікальне, бо воно знаходиться
на міграційному маршруті птахів
з півночі на південь.
І це дивовижно!
Я тут вперше бачу деяких птахів.
Ці місця часто турбують туристи, готелі.
У всьому світі землі біля моря дуже родючі, і фермери хочуть їх обробляти.
Волонтери захищають парк і добре роблять свою роботу.
Я скажу своїм друзям у Нідерландах,
що я знайшов рай для бьордвотчерів.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Марчук]
[Інтерв'юерка
Наталія Понеділок]
[Режисерка монтажу
Юрія Рублевська]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Асистентка продюсерки
Наталія Вишинська]
[Субтитрувальниця
Валерія Діденко]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]